hey guys good evening everyone and and
welcome and thank you for making the
time tonight to to come to church
this this fulfilled your obligation for
the coming Sunday for those of you need
to know that but thank you thank you for
coming out it's great to see the
congregation as large as it is tonight
under this single tent and for those of
you who may be a bit apprehensive
because you remember that movie Kingsman
this this and that way it doesn't in
that way so though I can't thank you and
as you can see from this evening here
again at place station we've decided to
mix it up a little bit and the way that
we're doing our e3 presentation this
year you know we look at what the
stories have we tell to tell and and and
the things that we want to impart to our
fans here with us and their fans on the
live feed worldwide and that changes our
design design ideas around what we can
do for this show so tonight we're going
to have rather than a bombardment of new
creative we're going to take all of you
on a journey deeper into some of the key
titles we've talked about before but
we're gonna talk about them in a
different way tonight a deeper way so
you can learn about what's going on with
these games and what's coming up in the
future you know what we've looked at
here at worldwide studios with inside
Sony interactive entertainment we really
want to take our love for gaming and
make it sing and make it sing very
loudly it's a gaming industry that
sometimes called but certainly inside
our studios we see gaming as a vocation
it's a calling it's what we do it's what
we have to do our teams our creatives
and Studios and designers they have
stories to tell and things they want to
show you in places they'd like to take
you that's what we're trying to do here
at PlayStation this coming year is going
to be all about those kind of games that
we can deliver to you in a way that's
going to blow your minds and tonight we
beginning here in this tent we've this
church tent we've created here in Los
Angeles to let you start that journey
with us and let us tell you our stories
for the next hour or so so without
further ado it is my great honor and my
unique privilege to invite to the stage
introduce to you Gustavo Santo Dale
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but help lanai to make a little brown
dammit little Sadie anastagia dude went
back home jumped into bed 45
and
[Music]
[Applause]
I hate these things
it's only money
your old man mother they didn't in today
what happened the big lecture about my
patrols don't go here don't go there
funny how involved he gets one of your
scheduled go well yeah
she's that but not quite the show
maybe guys to eat sleep back together
not gonna happen
yeah say something
make it one week Ellie hey what's easel
off I'm here aren't I Deena Jessie
they don't forget we leave at first
light to get some rest
yes sir
[Music]
such a day come on as you start with me
okay I have a very serious question for
you
how bad my spell
[Music]
my a hot pile of garbage oh okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every guy in this room is staring at
maybe they're staring at you
[Music]
and I
maybe they're jealous area
and
just a girl not a threat
I'll bet
I think they should be terrified
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
spread out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she went into the grass watch yourself
really
[Music]
what well she came through here double
back go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my daughter
you should be terrified
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a new look at the Last of Us
part two we're here live in Los Angeles
at the PlayStation III showcase we're
taking a quick intermission while folks
move along to the next part of the
experience we'll have a little bit more
to share on that later and I am joined
by my good friend Ryan clementsl Oh mr.
Shue and how are you I'm good it's such
a pleasure to be here at the PlayStation
showcase and it's gonna be a huge night
for worldwide studios a little later
when the showcase resumes and what
better guests to have for joining us
about worldwide studios then the
chairman of worldwide to do is mr. Shawn
Layden yes sir I thought you were just
on stage how did you get up here so fast
pneumatic tube that I was dropped into
and right across to the studio here
right over here oh it's great to be here
and I think it was a very a very
powerful start for your food program for
this year that's right there's much more
to come but I do want to zero in on the
last of us part two yeah just for a
moment you know as chairman of worldwide
studios you work very closely with
Naughty Dog these guys need no
introduction
indeed and I'm curious from your
perspective where is their head at when
it comes to developing this game where
the wrists are headed I mean they are
they're everywhere they're looking at
what can do in the next iteration of the
Last of Us series and I think what we
saw tonight I mean that that piece of
content was was so impactful I mean the
whole relationship between Elie and Dena
going into the combat sequence really
shows that they're pulling out all the
stops over at Naughty Dog and they're
gonna have a very broad and ranging game
that's not going to make you only only
work at it as a player but you're gonna
have to just think as a person which way
you're coming up against and I can't
wait to see more of that that was first
game played we saw their of the last was
part two looking obviously incredible
and speaking of incredible
I mean worldwide studios lately I mean
it's just been unbelievable horizon you
had God of War which needs no
introduction
and Detroit become human I mean what is
this secret and what are you doing over
there at worldwide studios what's going
on there
the rule number one is do no harm right
a lot of ways my job is just to move the
boulders out of the road to make sure
that the creative talent can get where
they need to go you know provide backup
provide scope you know provide
generalized you know advice about where
we can take this as an industry and as
and as a gaming culture but honestly
we've got 13 studios worldwide we try to
give them as much creative control as
possible and just help support them
through to their vision that's kind of
what we've been trying to do here the
last dozen years or so we'll go buy
studios I think right now certainly the
ps4 era you're seeing a lot of that
coming into coming into play right now
that's great to hear that and you mean
speaking about making fans happy I mean
there's I think there's a question that
I've been getting a whole lot and it has
to do with God of War you know it's a
celebrated game it's sold extremely well
it has a huge legion of fans and one of
the things I wanted to mention was you
know I get a lot of tweets about new
game+ I know is this is this something
that you and Santa Monica studio are
evaluating for God oh boy you know it's
crazy with the advent of social media
we've got we get a lot of real-time
feedback right from the fans in the
community and we listen to that and God
knows my twitter feed is is filled up
with a lot of stuff that we could talk
about here and not talk about it all but
it's all important we take it all
seriously and New Game+ was something
that came through really strong really
hard through that kind of feedback loop
and I'm happy to say the day that the
teams are working on it and we should
have some more updates on that we'll put
that through the blog but it's gonna
happen all right definitely as someone
who miraculously finished god of war
with a two-year-old at home that makes
me very happy I will somehow find scary
I will find thank you he wasn't watching
ok kids don't drive them asleep but yeah
thank you so much on and it's great to
hear that you and the amazing team at
Santa Monica studio are making that
happen if we don't create functionality
and features that allow people to spend
more time in the worlds we build that's
by definition a good thing
excellent fantastic is a New Game+ that
is confirmed that is coming to god of
war we'll have full details on
PlayStation Blog shortly we have a lot
more to talk about - yeah and actually
Sean I wanted to ask you about that
about a month ago you did something a
little bit out of the ordinary for our
team and you kind of came out and talked
about
the four main games think that we would
be highlighting tonight's PlayStation
showcase I was wondering what the
thought process was there well you know
every year we try to let the the stories
we have to tell design the experience
we're going to create and this year we
felt that them we really wanted to do is
take people on a journey deep into the
content deep into the four big pillar
games they were working on right now and
get them to see a bit more about the
stories you're trying to tell and the
way it's going to be expressed and what
they got out of it it's a really wide
range of of titles there anything from
the last of us to just Saul right now
through death stranding and and then
spider-man and ghosts so this year I
wanted people to know that don't come
here expecting to have some big flashy
new idea come out or some big surprise
come out come here and sit with us and
walk with us as we get through to see
the background stories and deep inside
that the games were working on wonderful
and we do have a lot more coming from
those worldwide studios games in the
showcase later tonight do you have any
personal games that you're most excited
about well they're all fabulous and I
think the teams are really crushing it
right across the board fair enough
but one thing I would say is there's one
of the games that we're having out today
that will be playable in three months
and available in stores and that's our
favorite webslinger
of course spider-man so we're gonna see
a lot of that tonight and I think the
folks at home should be happy with what
they're gonna get awesome Thank You Sean
Sean thank you so much for dropping by
always a pleasure to trade notes with
the chairman of worldwide studios it's
great to see you guys I'll head back to
the pneumatic tube station all right
please do and they're in the helmet we
do have a lot more in store coming up in
just a few minutes as the e3 Showcase
continues but in the meantime we also
have some other updates for you while we
wait during the short intermission so I
say we kick it off with a look at the
latest from the world of Call of Duty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get immediate access to Beck and black
naps and call of duty black ops 3 only
when you pre-order call of duty black
ops 4 from PlayStation Store welcome
back we are having the PlayStation III
showcase kicking off in just a few more
minutes or in a short intermission
period here but we've got some good
stuff to talk about we've got some good
friends as well yeah
Meredith Mullen ari and Ramon Russell
welcome what's happening that's gonna
have you guys back good to be back right
before the showcase
absolutely yeah excellent so I say we
keep this move in here and when it comes
to call of duty we know that a bunch of
remastered Maps from black ops 1 and
black ops 2 are making their way to call
of duty black ops for this October on
launch day but what we just learned here
is that those Maps those classic maps
are coming to black ops 3 as well for
those who pre-order black ops 4 on
PlayStation Store oh that's pretty
awesome but what if I don't own call of
duty black ops 3 well that's where it
gets a little more interesting my friend
so tonight we are actually doing a
surprise PlayStation Plus game drop and
that is going to be black ops 3 black
ops 3 is coming to PlayStation Plus
later tonight
yeah that's also yeah it's very nice
this is why I love e3 because not only
do we get to share awesome news with our
audience but PlayStation Plus
subscribers get a little treat tasty
treat little MIDI 3 Supply Drop yeah you
know we've been sharing a lot of good
news we got to share 5 really cool
announcements last week we did our
countdown kind of ramping up for
tonight's big showcase that's right we
had the countdown to e3 and that was
five game reveals and updates over span
of five days lot of great stuff
announced let's take a quick look back
at the highlights
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
have to figure out what happened
wake up focus from the creators of free
and flippin day look like you've seen
comes a heartfelt story really who are
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back we're just a few minutes
away from the e3 PlayStation showcase I
mean I am when I say a few minutes I
mean we're really good let's keep moving
here there was a lot of great stuff here
oh and we could see the crowd is seated
the people are about ready to go this
shows about to continue about to move
into the big event yeah it was great to
see the countdown stuff but I do think
that there's like maybe one more thing
we can sneak in there before we cut it
right to the showcase yeah let's squeeze
it in let's seize it in okay so this
next franchise boasts a huge loyal
community of nearly 6 billion hours
incredible staff yeah they play that so
much a lot they do and we're gonna take
a look at the next chapter right now
[Applause]
a lot of bitters
and
just
overdose of this
I'm a strong
[Music]
to let things just
[Applause]
I'm just king
thus far
[Music]
I can't leave
[Music]
yeah that was a powerful new look at
destiny - forsaken is coming out
September 4th on ps4 a lot of great
enhancements and content for that one
and yeah it looks it looks really good
there's a lot of buzz about that gambit
mode coming up and guess what if you're
ready three you can play it at our booth
not too bad there's barely any time
because we're about to get to the show
that's right we are really seconds away
when it comes down to it from the rest
of a play stations III showcase thank
you so much for watching we've got a lot
more in store tonight but for now I
think it's almost time I think it's
almost time should get to it I think why
keep people waiting let's get to we have
so much cover okay got a lot more in
store so let's check it out live right
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
simples please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Nova come
[Music]
[Music]
where are they
[Music]
the fastest enough us next summer
our Salvage photostats 'i'm it work one
minute
[Applause]
but since um right
[Music]
[Applause]
gin you're late you're impatient
where's the monk the bastards beat me to
him
now they're torturing him at the temple
come on here we need him classical
town
Ricky didn't know a member syco bridge
we strike quietly but they killed among
hard
Toxocara easy
yes tonight
I'll guard the exits just get
[Music]
in a mismatch
[Music]
Sonia rock dust sushi mug buy the stuff
off lock button
please I do not understand that we
become our own army Oh speech a oven
sucked gob
[Music]
he called reinforcements we have to move
[Music]
[Music]
Masako stand aside Jin
you betrayed my family
run
we fight mungus win they already won
[Music]
you were my friend give
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here they're coming that's our enemy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the oldest house is a shifting place
our rules
and rituals
[Music]
you can keep traveling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anybody there something's not right
[Music]
what are you under arrest
stay back sir I've got this what are you
doing
get off No
Jesus Christ
[Applause]
money's in my accounts always play and
don't make my mistake
if you see one of those things uniform
or not
you do not hesitate whatever it takes to
save this city
surprised you made it this far they
didn't for my extraction survivals your
responsibility goddamnit
will you help me of course it's
impressive display of strength
but we never meant for this to happen
it's coming it's coming back
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for the school James and the co-creator
of Rick and Morty hey what's up
everybody I'm bathtub guy and we're here
at e3 to take some looks at this new
game I'm going to show you right now
trover saves the universe
let's give it a look I'm the bathtub guy
I'm always in my bathtub but you know
that's not about me right now this game
I just saw hold I'm playing it right now
look at me I'm a cool fish over here
playing this pool game
Jesus Christ oh my god somebody call
seven one one because that's the
emergency dial number for this in this
weird get part of the galaxy because
this is a sci-fi based thing help
he's got electrocuted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yo ho yo ho a pirate's life for me
perhaps cuz we get to be pirates again
yep
you always did like this world still
it's a real shame we don't have a bigger
ship
[Music]
[Music]
you back in the organization yes
surprising isn't it jack
don't you give this creep the time of
day Sora sander it's the couch mustn't
strike a Pyrus aboard ship when said
parent offers to confabulate I am
looking
for a box surah only they come for us
well arendelle is safer with me staying
up here open please go away
[Music]
send the Unversed collected enough
screams and sadness for those children
yeah they were trashing our company on
the rock that you're following her maybe
she's one of the seven pure lights with
the music seven hearts No set your heart
free and at the end you'll finally
realize what destiny has in store for
you in fact your reward might be right
around the corner
hey axel bike in the love got your hair
too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
preaches the man who delivers
[Music]
Cheers
Carroll allergy
so you have tombs like me
what's your level I've got the extension
factor but I think you got maybe you can
see them right no but I can sense him
when I come work for me
must be tough out here on your own I
make deliveries that's all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
headed into ten
which yourself those things never stay
gone for them
the time for fast-forwards whatever it
touches but it can't wash everything
away pastors won't they go I'll see you
around Sam or bridges
[Music]
what's your status
my status is [ __ ] there's possible you
sit up the way know they're closing in
on my position I have to move before
they realize I'm in here trigger a point
out you'll go back sure but the
surrounding area will still be greater
I got an idea
[Music]
I grew up to why today I keep stat I'm
fall away too late you still don't know
who I am do you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the raft is secure but I can't reach
them over radio their comms must be down
and what's your status already here
Yuriy I thought you said it was secure
it was let's go maybe it's not as bad as
it looks
love the optimism but in my experience
when it looks bad it's usually worse
look out
you okay yeah
welcome to the park just in time for the
fireworks
they parole boy
electrum why is he letting everyone out
I'll head for the main control center
and see how bad the situation got it
I'll go join the party
[Music]
everyone just quietly go back into your
cells and lock the door behind you
like fish to the fair that doesn't sound
good
oh hi RINO
spider surprised is he talking about
hey what's your status me just trapped
in a prison with every criminal I put
away in the last eight years no biggie
electoral must be working for some
this is too good to be true scorpion can
you hold on a minute I was in the middle
of a phone call and it was business
don't let up lost you take it there you
okay
it's not really electro Rondo and now
scorpion are all on the loose what's
going on in the rest of the prison I'll
give you a sitrep soon okay huh keep
tracking electro
come on spider-man I thought this was a
shape gotta stop this guy
you tell me who you're working for I'll
go easy on you can't stock left planet
did you still try never takes me up on
that offer
wotcher long time no see we're gonna
have so much fun
sorry no time to talk
okay I got the security cameras back
online
well it look like the entire population
of the round
five of your worst enemies that are now
on the loose
[Music]
first I thought you were serious
area I have to go some of them are
heading into the city
keep chasing the party's almost document
electro stop
how do you like my new suit
dashing where'd you get it it's an
exclusive club
he said not to kill him good idea in
fact we don't have to do this at all you
don't want to be definitely boss
[Music]
[Applause]
Jim
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh Pelly I think they should be
terrified of me
[Music]
not his team
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was the PlayStation III showcase a
lot to take in there was a ton of great
worldwide studios titles we actually had
a little more to share here
coming right up we're gonna have first
live gameplay of Marvel's spider-man
right here just a couple of minutes we
have a new game to announce we have some
other stuff to talk about too what a
show top highlights go oh my goodness go
sushi would look absolutely incredible
those that color palette was in yeah
same yeah did you grow up with samurai
movies absolutely yeah thank you
resonates here come on that looks so
good I know a lot of us fans been
waiting for that one and it was like I'm
over you're like I'm not really sure I
know what this is and then as soon as he
turned his head I was like good re for
style over the shoulder camera action
it's kind of like the ultimate dream if
they were gonna remake Resident Evil 2
that's what I would want so awesome
stuff Ryan nice and gory as Meredith
said backstage death stranding I now
we'd now have more questions yes it
looks as if I mean I don't want to make
any promises but it looks as if we were
getting kind of an allusion to a lot of
gameplay under there and kind of what
the character of Sam is gonna be doing
in this very unusual world that is
inhabited by some very unusual and scary
things and people consume strange and
unusual babies continue to be a theme
yeah it wasn't am it what we're gonna
find out there but yeah so I ton of
great stuff in the show overall I mean
neo to that was a crowd-pleaser I was
one that was great to see get out there
we got an update on Kingdom Hearts 3 we
got a lot of other great stuff we had a
new remedy game already a control really
stylish trailer really looking though
just I want to learn more about that one
I mean it just looks like wizards and
like I don't know what it was really
stylish I would expect no less from
remedy but I got to say I think my
favorite was marvel spiderman spiderman
look and that was incredible we have
these legendary villains are back we had
rhino a lecture of vulture I'm missing
some who
welcome back we just saw Sony's e3 2018
press conference there was a lot of
gameplay in there and a lot to break
down so we're gonna get right to it I'm
Callie I'm joined by Michael hi um hello
Jay Decker hello it's more Hussein what
uh all right so then we got a lot to
cover I guess let's just start with the
last of us that was the first thing
inside into chronological order like we
did you you soft
okay sure oh damn I'm still like I'm
still recovering a little bit from
everything I didn't even like we
obviously didn't play but I was still
feeling tense like my heart was pounding
as Ellie was sneaking through those
environments and I think one thing that
really stood out to me was how
interactive she is in the environment
like she moves through it naturally like
the way she was like squeezing between
like the aisles and that run down with
that convenience store or something like
that and the way she was like pulled out
from under the car after crawling on
there under there and just seeing all
those animations it seems seems very
very polished yeah and I don't like the
kind of they opens with quite a like an
unassuming tender moment like you have
speaking to this guy and then like out
of nowhere this other girl appears and
obviously she gets led onto the dance
floor and they share they have like they
talk about she says I'm just a girl not
a threat that's what it sounded like to
me oh yeah I was like but they should be
scared they should be scared of you and
they kiss and then the way they kind of
like transition into like her slitting
someone's throat dropping the body and
being like God I was brutal perfectly
speaks to what the first game was kind
of going for like in the natural
follow-on from the first game it's a
girl first game was about kind of like
this girl losing her innocence in a lot
of ways right like and hard trying to
get over the things that she's missed
and go through this harsh world and the
second game is about kind of trying to
reckon from the wall you tell reconcile
that tenderness Druckman specifically
said that the first theme the theme of
the first game was love and I think this
game is hate and you get you definitely
get that through with Ellie I mean she
has this really tender moment with
whoever that girl is I don't think they
said her name I think the guy she was
with was Jesse that first of all like
Michael and I are in here like a gay
teen let's go but
I was really excited about that that was
just like such a beautiful scene and
then and then she goes into this
extremely violent takedown that was is
so emotionally charged a lot like not
your dog are amazing at telling stories
but like this shows that I mean this
this is this is probably just like a
segment from the game or it could be a
bespoke trailer for this bit but like
the craft the storytelling is like very
very evident in that as well the way it
does uses the kind of like the the kiss
to transition between a kind of tender
moment and something brutal and then
back again it says everything about what
this game is yeah and the kind of
character that Ellie is now and what
she's gonna be struggling with and I
think in a demon that she's gonna be
yeah throughout this game like if that's
like Druckman says that it's like this
game is gonna be I suspect like a lot
about her struggle between like
realizing like who is my friend like
yeah and who is my like who's my ally
who's my enemy like even though I'm I
know this this girl like even if you've
tracked back to um was it
the DLC after was behind yeah and it's
like she almost it's like she's carrying
on from there I've been here before I've
had this relationship that just like
ended in total heartbreak and moving on
to this it's like I feel like she's
thinking back to those moments and it's
just she's got gone a lot older too and
she's carrying on from her journey with
Joel and she just looks so confused or
and not necessarily confused but
conflicted at all times
yeah even even in combat like when she
was when she was like hacking on that
dude with a with a damn machete or
something like she knows like it has
such an intense look on her face even in
that dance moment where she be like
smiling or whatever but she never felt
like she was enjoying herself like she
can't separate herself all the [ __ ]
she's been through another interesting
thing too we never saw Joel but it was
clear that this character right here had
mentioned to him he was like hey your
dad always seems to get weird whenever
you're going out and it's like I